[Music]
to date scientists have found over 925
000 species of insects
and there is one man still determined to
find more
[Music]
meet dr isaidi he is an entomologist but
he doesn't always work in your typical
lab that's right he tracks to the
patagonian ice fields searching for new
insect species that have been hiding for
over 200 million years
due to the frigid and drastically
changing climate there is very little
information on the insects that inhabit
the area
every day is different for me i'm
looking for creatures smaller than my
pinky nail so i'm always searching for
the tiniest indication of any insect
life
this year eastside east stumbled upon a
new pool of water among the vegetation
it's there that i found something that
i've never seen before
[Music]
the coloration on the bottom of the
insect varying from other species he
said he took the insect back to his lab
and ended up making history discovering
this new species was the most amazing
thing it felt as though all of my hard
work had paid off i couldn't wait to
share with the rest of the world this
only motivated isaidi further but in
order to be successful in his search for
new species he's needed some other
unexpected skills
sometimes i feel like i'm an extreme
athlete i usually carry over 80 pounds
on my back i take my microscopes my
cameras vials and anything else i might
need to document this expedition it's
also extremely important to ecite that
he's able to get to each new location
with a low carbon footprint i always
manage to bike hike swim or rap
but climate change and shifting
conditions can also make his work
extremely dangerous
melting glaciers can sometimes cause an
outburst vlog which could be fatal if
i'm not prepared and if i'm not wearing
my protective gear my skin could burn
just from being exposed to the freezing
water for more than 10 seconds isaiah
feels it is not only his mission but his
responsibility to continue this work
with more than 40 possible species under
review east id has no plans of slowing
down i'm working against the clock
because the homes of these insects are
rapidly disappearing due to climate
change and human impact i hope to
continue studying them and to discover
their hidden worlds before our
biodiversity is changed forever